[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Sonntagabend zu gut 10 Minuten
Nachrichten viel Fußball gleich von Rudi
hallo schönen guten Abend schauen wir
auf unsere großen Themen
ein Mann viel Macht Chinas Staatschef
cheesingping wird für eine bislang
beispiellose dritte Amtszeit als
Generalsekretär der Kommunistischen
Partei bestätigt
heißt der neue britische Premier Vichy
suneck der Ex-Finanzminister geht
offiziell ins Rennen die meisten
Abgeordneten seiner Partei hat er wohl
hinter sich
und Spitzenspiel in der
Frauenfußball-Bundesliga die
Wolfsburgerin festigen mit einem Sieg
über Bayern ihre Tabellenführung
[Musik]
potenzielle Rivalen hatte er bereits
verdrängt loyale Anhänger in Position
gebracht und so konnte shishing Ping
heute wie erwartet seine Macht ausbauen
beim Treffen der Kommunistischen Partei
Chinas wurde er für eine dritte Amtszeit
als Generalsekretär bestätigt
China ist mit rund 1,4 Milliarden
Menschen das bevölkerungsreichste Land
der Welt und nach den USA die
zweitgrößte Volkswirtschaft als
langfristiges Ziel China militärisch und
wirtschaftlich zur Weltmacht führen
innenpolitisch muss er dabei nun keine
Gegenrede mehr fürchten über einen
Staatschef auf dem Zenit seiner Macht
Miriam Steimer
in China kommt die Macht durch diese Tür
sie besteht ausschließlich aus Männern
so mächtig wie ich hier den Ping heute
war kein chinesischer Parteiführer mehr
seit Staatsgründer Mao zu dumm
hi verkündet selbst dass er noch mal
fünf Jahre Parteichef bleibt mindestens
im März wird er sich dann auch ein
drittes Mal zum Präsidenten bestimmen
lassen die Begrenzung auf zwei
Amtszeiten hat er abgeschafft es geht
ihm um die Macht es geht ihm aber auch
um seinen Platz in den Geschichtsbüchern
er möchte die Person sein er möchte der
partei-führer gewesen sein der China
wieder zu einer alten Stärke
zurückgeführt hat es ist als würden
sieben Pinks auf der Bühne stehen denn
der Parteichef hat sein höchstes
Führungsgremium ausschließlich mit
vertrauten besetzt alle Anhänger anderer
Parteiströmungen sind raus
schiebericht mit den Partei Regeln
sowohl was Altersbeschränkungen als auch
Vorerfahrung angeht
bemerkenswert ist zum Beispiel die
Nummer 2 Lied Jan dürfte neuer
problemminister werden er war
verantwortlich für das Chaos während des
zwei-monatigen harten lockdowns im
Frühjahr in Shanghai das wichtigste
Kriterium für die Besetzung der Posten
ist jetzt Loyalität
das ist die Krönungszeremonie für Chi er
konzentriert die Macht der Partei in
seiner Hand statt Kollektiv mit seinen
Kadern führt er sie als Alleinherrscher
unter den Männern ist auch keiner der in
fünf Jahren als Nachfolger in Frage käme
hier den pink stellt sich darauf ein
noch länger zu bleiben
im Vereinigten Königreich geht das
Rennen um die Nachfolge der scheidenden
Premierministerin Trust weiter heute hat
der ehemalige Finanzminister sunek
offiziell sein Hut in den Ring geworfen
er hatte als erster Kandidat die
erforderlichen 100 Unterstützerinnen und
Unterstützer aus den Reihen der
tori-abgeordneten hinter sich versammelt
wer wird nächster britischer premier
Andreas Stamm in London kann sich Sonic
bereits sicher fühlen oder kann ihm Ex
premier Boys Johnson noch in die Quere
kommen
sicher fühlen kann er sich auf keinen
Fall so viel steht fest auch wenn er das
Momentum genießt er fleißig Unterstützer
einsammelt und eben er der erste ist der
offiziell überhaupt diese hohe Hürde
genommen hat nämlich mehr als 100 der
357 konservativen Abgeordneten hinter
sich zu versammeln sein Lager ist klar
warum er der richtige Kandidat ist er
ist der Einzige der in dieser ja
wirtschaftspolitisch chaotischen
Situation nachlist Trust mit seinem
Background als Finanzminister und
Investmentbanker in Frage kommt aber die
große Frage schafft es eben noch ein
Kandidat diese Hunderter Hürde zu nehmen
und dann kommt es zu einer Stichwahl und
ist dieser Kandidat Boris Johnson sein
Team sagt ja er hat die 100 das ist
nicht offiziell bestätigt und nur er
könnte die Tories bei der nächsten Wahl
zu einem Sieg führen aus dem Umfragetief
heraus ja und jetzt eben kommt es zu
dieser stichwahlschaft des Polster dann
entscheidet nicht mehr die Fraktion
sondern die Partei Basis und da ist
schon zum beliebter dann wäre er der
Favorit es wurde eine weitere Woche mit
sehr vielen politischen Turbulenzen hier
in London am Ende könnte ein
premiersunak ein ansonsten stehen oder
sogar die Ausrufung von Neuwahlen weil
der Streit um die Rückkehr des
skandalträchtigen premiers Boris Johnson
die Konservativen ja wirklich zerreißen
könnte sie werden das weiter für uns
beobachten Dankeschön Andreas Stau
in Rom hat Italiens neue
Ministerpräsidentin Meloni offiziell die
Amtsgeschäfte übernommen in einer
traditionellen Zeremonie übergab
Vorgänger Draghi ein silbernes Glöckchen
dass sie anschließend bei der ersten
Sitzung des Kabinetts benutzte Meloni
führt mit ihren neofaschistischen
fratelli d'Italia ein
drei-parteienbündnis an es steht
politisch so weit rechts wie keine
italienische Regierung seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg
schauen wir in die Ukraine dort hat
Russland seine Angriffe auf Energie und
militärinfrastruktur fortgesetzt in der
südukrainischen Stadt mikolaie trafen
russische Raketen ein Wohnviertel dabei
wurden ukrainischen Angaben zufolge drei
Menschen verletzt zwei Wohngebäude ein
Spielplatz und ein Lagerhaus sollen
beschädigt oder zerstört worden sein
Sachsens Ministerpräsident Michael
Kretschmer spricht sich dafür aus dass
Deutschland nach Ende des ukrainekrieges
wieder russisches Erdgas nutzt dazu
müsse auch die beschädigte Gaspipeline
Nord Stream 1 wieder repariert werden so
Kretschmer in der Bild am Sonntag Kritik
kommt unter anderem von seinen
Parteikollegen dem Ministerpräsidenten
Schleswig-Holsteins ich finde wir
sollten jetzt nicht die nächste Debatte
darüber führen dass wir uns wieder in
Abhängigkeiten begeben so Daniel Günther
seine Stimme gilt als eine der
wichtigsten der ukrainischen
Gegenwartsliteratur Serie shardan
erhielt heute in der Frankfurter
Paulskirche den Friedenspreis des
Deutschen Buchhandels
ausgezeichnet wird ein Autor und Musiker
der zudem seit Monaten in seiner
Heimatstadt hakif als Freiwilliger Hilfe
leistet Peter Theisen
ein Friedenspreis in Zeiten des Krieges
als der Autor und Musiker Serie shardan
in der Frankfurter Paulskirche diese
große Auszeichnung erhält appelliert er
an die deutschen das ukrainische Volk
weiterhin entschieden in seinem Kampf zu
unterstützen
wenn wir jetzt in Angesicht dieses
blutigen dramatischen und von Russland
entfernten Kriegers über Frieden
sprechen wollen einige eines
implantatsache nicht zu Kenntnis nehmen
ohne Gerechtigkeit gibt es keinen
Frieden Serie schau dann kennt den Krieg
aus eigener Anschauung in haarkiff wo
erlebt er unterstützt als Freiwilliger
die ukrainische Armee engagiert sich für
den Widerstand sammelt Spenden kauft
Lebensmittel Autos und Drohnen und
findet eindringlicher Worte für das
Grauen seine Einträge in sozialen Medien
sind eine Art Chronik des Krieges
geworden daraus ist auch ein Buch
entstanden Himmel über haarkiff dass die
ersten fünf Kriegsmonate schildert ein
unmittelbares unverblümtes Zeugnis des
Krieges Poesie kann dieses beklemmende
Gefühl dass die Welt in ihrer
Einzelteile zerfällt
für kurze Zeit lindern
und um es mit dem diesjährigen
friedenspreisträger sehe ich ja dann zu
sagen natürlich können Bücher den Krieg
nicht beenden aber Bücher können ihr im
Krieg helfen du selbst zu bleiben
schafft es seine Wut auf die russischen
Aggressoren in große Literatur und
Humanität zu verwandeln und ist so ein
würdiger Träger des Friedenspreises
[Applaus]
Energydrink Sportvereine Fernsehsender
Dietrich matheschitz schuf mit seiner
Marke RED BULL einem perium nun ist der
Österreicher im Alter von 78 Jahren
gestorben
Mateschitz prägte eine neue Form von
Marketing er kaufte Sportteams auf der
ganzen Welt und förderte
extremsport-events kritik gab es an
seinem Sender ServusTV der
Verschwörungstheoretikern eine Plattform
geboten haben soll sein Vermögen wurde
zuletzt auf mehr als 20 Milliarden Euro
geschätzt
kommen wir zum Sport und der
Frauen-Bundesliga da gab es ja ein
besonderes Highlight heute absolut die
ersten gegen die zweiten der Tabelle und
in diesem Topspiel der Frauen Bundesliga
setzen sich die Deutschen Meisterinnen
des VfL Wolfsburg gegen die
Vizemeisterinnen des FC Bayern München
mit zwei zu eins durch damit bauen die
Wolfsburgerinnen ihre Tabellenführung
weiter aus eine umkämpfte Partie vor
prächtiger Kulisse
das bundesligaspitzenspiel zum ersten
Mal in der großen Wolfsburger Arena vor
über 21.000 Fans der Tabellenführer aus
Wolfsburg braucht lange um ins Spiel zu
finden und dann doch top Torjägerin Eva
pajor mit der 1:0 Führung zur Halbzeit
Bayern in der zweiten Halbzeit bemüht
und doch das 2:0 erzielen die
Gastgeberin durch diese Direktabnahme
von Svenja Hut zum 2:0 München kommt in
der letzten Viertelstunde zur noch mal
heran Klara Bühl mit dem
Anschlusstreffer zum 1 zu 2 an diesem
Nachmittag aber dann doch zu wenig
Wolfsburg schlägt Bayern München mit
zwei zu eins
und in der Männer Bundesliga gewinnt der
Tabelle letzte VfL Bochum gegen
Tabellenführer Union Berlin mit 2:1
Bochum Skipper Manuel Riemann hält dabei
sogar einen vollelfmeter Union hat jetzt
nur noch einen Punkt Vorsprung vor den
Bayern
der Schweizer Marco Odermatt gewinnt das
Auftaktrennen der alpinen Weltcup-Saison
im Riesenslalom von Sölden siegt der
Olympiasieger mit deutlichem Vorsprung
vor der Konkurrenz als bester Deutscher
feiert Alexander Schmid eine Top Ten
Platzierung
er hat gut lachen hat sich auf Anhieb
für die WM im Februar qualifiziert Platz
8 für Alexander Schmid einziger
deutscher heute im plasmo der erste
Saisonsieger ist der vom letzten Jahr am
Rettenbachferner Marco oder matt macht
nach Olympia und Gesamtweltcupsieg da
weiter wo er im März aufgehört hat
gewinnt vor dem Slowenen kranjic und
Henrik Kristoffersen aus Norwegen die
Österreicher gehen leer aus beim
Heimrennen Triumph dagegen für die
Schweiz
ja geht wieder los mit Wintersport Jana
das war's danke schön Rudi und so wird
das Wetter im Süden regnet es teils
anhaltend vereinzelt kann auch ein
Gewitter dabei sein sonst bleibt es bei
einem Mix aus Sonne und Wolken meist
trocken im Nordwesten kommen am
Nachmittag Schauer auf bei einem
lebhaften Südwestwind werden 15 bis 22
Grad erreicht